Speaker 1: Let's speak to some people in the
audience, right? I mean, I think that that
makes absolute and perfect sense. You can
join the discussion on our discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. We use the waiting
lobby to indicate that you would like to speak
to me. And of course, do not send me any direct
messages. We have a system. Get in the waiting
lobby. If you send me direct messages saying
David, David, please put me on. Unfortunately,
I have to mute you and I will never hear
from you again. That's the way it works.
Let's go first to our friend Jen in
Providence. Jen, great to have you back on.
Speaker 5: Hey, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 5: All right. Great. So, you know,
living in a liberal area like New England,
a lot of people have that peace of mind
thinking, oh, as far as abortion rights,
they're never going to come for us. We're going
to be safe up here. But do you think it really is
only a matter of time until they just really try
to make it federal and try to creep up? I mean,
Rhode Island is even almost purple. It's not
solid blue like Massachusetts is. Right. Do
you think we're in any danger in the future?
Speaker 1: I think it would be a bad idea to
assume that they're never coming for abortion
with a federal abortion ban. In fact, there's
already people talking about it. There's already
people saying, hey, listen, if we can get rid of
Roe v Wade, maybe a total ban would actually be
a possibility. So I think to your point, Jan,
it would be at one's own peril to put our guard
down and to say, well, as long as we just lobby
for it to remain legal within the states in which
we live, we don't have to worry about it. That
seems extremely dangerous and naive to me. Now,
I'm not saying they will get a federal abortion
ban necessarily anytime soon, but they we don't
have to wonder whether they're thinking about it.
They're telling us that they're thinking about it.
Speaker 5: Yeah. What's interesting about the
design of Providence, too, we get to see the
effects of if they did go through with this ban
on one street, there is a Planned Parenthood, a
homeless shelter and Department of Human Services.
So it's kind of showing that triad of what happens
if these women are meant to have kids that they
can't afford. Yeah, but none of these people who
are screaming pro-life are going to, you know,
the homeless shelter and donating. And they're
the same ones. They get mad when they have to go
by like the food stamp in the welfare office.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. It is incredible. And
as I've said before, a lot of the
very same people who want to make
it impossible or illegal to get
an abortion are unwilling to say,
well, we should expand and codify the child
tax credit at a higher level. We should provide
contraception, comprehensive sex education, all
of these different things. Not only are they
hypocrites, but they're dangerous hypocrites.
Speaker 5: Exactly. All right. Well, I thank
you so much. I'll let you get to everybody else.
Speaker 1: All right. Jen from Providence. Look,
did you see how she other than that one
audio glitch? She gets right to the question.
She knows other people are waiting. What a
great call. Really a fantastic phone call.